hey bhishan I'm actually I'm not working
tonight I just I wanted you to know I
saw another gif Antony it had way more
sex than Brokeback Mountain but I think
I liked it better it was called OD
writes Tristan I think that was a porn
bhishan I just want to say thank you all
so very much for coming to celebrate
Chase's big day wait where is chase oh
yeah that's my big a biffed it right out
of the gate what happened um I just went
to get his little body jacked up for the
Kids Choice Awards he's presenting Best
Kiss next month with Meghan Trainor yeah
he is yeah so I told him he can only
have like a dozen rides for lunch and
he's lying on the floor back at the
hotel room on a tarp Daniel no no no
that's done but we can still celebrate
my children who are here because I'm
equally proud of both of you two my Care
Bear who's working so hard at becoming
an actor I am an actor now mama I'm
acting and brookie my little dancing
queen I haven't danced in 12 years and
Lance America's next top shoe designer
you know it actually came up with three
new ideas for shoes today one lace is on
the bottom two shoes but invisible three
edible shoes wait I'm sorry so you just
walk around in the shoes all day and
then eat them oh yeah if you're hungry
oh my god I wish it was still okay to
say retarded oh no wait mamacita chase
dreams loves all people of all mental
faculties Jesus Christ yes even Jesus
Christ oh my god mom I broke up the
class
what yes two weeks ago oh honey are you
doing okay yes I'm great I'm Way better
than I was before
no offense Lance what cuz I finally get
to figure out what it is that I want to
do with my life I already decided that
I'm gonna see 50 states Steve I'm gonna
travel see you mom I'm gonna drive
across the country movie the travel
agent travel writer travel photographer
all the things mom
free to be me which rhymed I'm gonna be
a rapper rap critic point is mom is that
I'm rock solid we both are
Carrie had a callback today
[Applause]
[Music]
really it's nothing it's just a it's a
commercial where I smell a fart yeah I
just I just gotta like oh that was good
it was very natural full disclosure I
just farted moments ago so it's the eggs
I do smell it now anyway the point is
mom we might not be the hot new twink or
whatever but all three of your kids are
hot equally successful Millennials what
you guys aren't Millennials it's 1982
and after so those actually chances Gen
Z name is chase
you